amy hey how's it going
uh it's going all right how are you uh
you know hanging in uh so how's the
history magazine these days
it's bloody jacob very bloody
okay
tell me not too much more but a little
bit more
vampires jacob we're working on a story
about vampires and the origins of the
dracula story
that sounds spooky okay uh what have you
found okay so you know count dracula
right
yeah it's bram stoker's novel and we're
looking into the you know the source
material for it
so it turns out count dracula is based
in part on an actual guy
he's known as vlad tepas or as his
enemies called him vlad the impaler ooh
okay
so he rolled back in the 1400s in what
is now romania
and so he dies
and his detractors write about how
brutal the guy was and you know they're
not really lying like vlad was pretty
brutal like he was a ruthless enemy
he actually did impale a bunch of people
on big pointy spikes to kill them i mean
not not somebody wanted to tangle with
yeah so years later bram stoker he's
researching a new novel he's writing
about a vampire
and so he's he goes to he goes to
romania and he's doing some research and
comes across this name dracula which is
a fabulous name for a vampire
it means son of the dragon and so he
bases his count dracula character in
part on vlad
so aside from a few details you know
stoker makes up the rest you know vlad
isn't nocturnal vlad wasn't sucking
people's blood he wasn't a vampire and
he definitely did not turn into a bat
do we know if he liked garlic
i think the jury is out on garlic i
think they were too busy writing about
the impaling to worry about the culinary
thing but i'll look into it
well i'll tell you amy what i've learned
is that that bat part has really stuck
um i've been working on a story about
bats and i gotta tell you they have a
lot of baggage
i mean for hundreds of years people have
seen bats as bloodsuckers and disease
carriers
just generally bad luck i mean well i
mean aren't they well here's the thing i
met this scientist named rodrigo
medellin and he's really helped me
understand why bats are our friends and
they help make a lot of good things
possible things that are in our life
every single day and they also occupy
this kind of magical and mysterious
place in our minds um and it's that
world that you know rodrigo really wants
to bring us into yeah but aren't there
vampires there
no vampires all right it's well i'm
gonna make it worth your while i promise
okay as long as it's safe i'm ready to
go with you all right cool
so it's probably not a surprise that a
bat researcher spends a lot of time in
caves
but what is a surprise at least to me
is how much those caves reinvigorate
rodrigo medellin
that's the most amazing feeling on earth
i always
use the opportunity to
be in a cave to reconnect with myself
they're like his own private portal to
some other world
when rodrigo goes into these caves he's
often with other people like students
but he finds ways to have the cave all
to himself once we're done with the
work etc i send everyone out of the cave
and i remain behind
just enjoying just soaking in the
peace the silence the tranquility
in an absolute
dark
environment
now i myself don't go into caves i think
they're pretty scary but rodrigo says
when you turn off your flashlight the
darkness in there is so profound it
becomes beautiful in its own way
it's like you're shrouded in
in
felt in like a
beautiful
silky feeling
that just
hugs you and welcomes you to an amazing
place in which
you
usually
as a human being you're not
considering as welcoming for you
in fact with nothing to see your body
puts your other senses on high alert
your nose picks up the smell of bats
especially their guano and your ears are
busy too
there's the flight of the bats flying
around you occasionally but there's also
uh the squealing of the bats themselves
when they are in their in their niches
in in the on the walls etc i mean with
all that going on it must be hard to
hear yourself think
well the first time that i take students
into a cave yes they there's so many
emotions and so many questions that they
have that it's very very difficult to
really
you know assume
a pose of tranquility and peace
but once you've done it for decades oh
my god i'm looking forward to the next
time i'm gonna be in a cave
rodrigo is on a quest to make people see
bats the same way he does with a sense
of wonder and awe
i mean think about it they're the only
mammal that can fly which is pretty
incredible
and there are more than 1400 different
bat species which makes them one of the
most diverse types of mammals
but the deck is stacked against them
hundreds of years of myth-making has
painted batz's spooky blood-sucking
disease-carrying villains
there's many animals that have a
negative
public image from snakes to spiders to
scorpions to sharks to bats
none of those animals do more
for your everyday life
quality
than bats
today many species of bats are at the
brink of extinction
and a world without bats could have
major ripple effects for the clothes
you're wearing right now for the food on
your table
and even for the cocktail you sip at the
end of a long day
put it this way
bats may not be the hero everyone wants
but right now
they're the hero we need
i'm jacob penner and this is overheard a
show where we eavesdrop on the wild
conversations we have here at nat geo
and follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world this week the man
on a mission to change how we see bats
one product that relies on bats is
tequila
we'll explain how rodrigo convinced
skeptical tequila producers to team up
with them and come on who wants to live
in a world with no tequila
plus why covet 19 misinformation is
putting bats in danger and how rodrigo
is set in the record straight
more after this
so i have to fess up that for the
longest time my knowledge of bats
started
and basically ended with halloween
i mean bats are spooky right and a story
i guess i assume that even studying bats
was kind of a creepy endeavor
it turns out at least according to
rodrigo medellin
i was totally wrong i am a professor of
ecology at the national autonomous
university of mexico
and i'm
lucky enough to be
one of the happiest people i know
today rodrigo is a national geographic
explorer at large he's been studying
bats and evangelizing for them for
decades
he's even picked up the nickname the
batman of mexico which i guess is
inevitable if you study bats long enough
but just like a comic book hero
rodrigo's journey started with a
mythical origin story
i i started with an interest on animals
from a very very early age i mean my
first word was not mama or dada or
doodoo my first word was flamingo
flamingo
flamingo yeah i mean i i said
my mom reflected it in my baby book
saying well little rodrigo said his
first word today he was looking at a pic
at the book with pictures of animals and
he was pointing at a flamingo and he
said gangling or something like that i
mean i gotta say if if i was if if my
kid did that i would be very impressed
don't get me wrong i think i'd also be a
little bit
hurt that they didn't want to say my
name first
and you would
the thought would also cross your mind
that there's something really weird with
your kids i mean
sorry but it is true now little rodrigo
would just inhale books about wildlife
anything he could get his hands on but
especially mammals
so one day when he's 11 years old he's
watching this mexican game show the 64
000 peso grand prize
rodrigo turns to his mom and says
you know if i could get on this show and
they asked me questions about mammals
i think i could win and my mom says no
no you you go play you're 11 years old
you're not supposed to be
know it all about mammals no no no go
play i insisted and insisted and
insisted that my mom finally took me to
the producers
now to be clear this was a game show for
adults
the producers completely dismissed
rodrigo
they told him and his mom look this
isn't some kind of parlor game and we're
just not interested
so rodrigo's mom threw down the gauntlet
and my mom said well ask the kid a
question if you think that he doesn't
know so they pulled a book and they
started asking questions about mammals
an eleven-year-old rodrigo nailed the
pop quiz
and soon enough they said well
congratulations because you're going to
be the first kid in the show so how'd it
go
it went really well but no i'm sorry to
disappoint you i did not win the 64 000
peso price
i was going for 32 000 pesos
and that is the question that i did not
answer
but my god did i ever win a prize
now this was back in the days when there
were only like three tv channels and no
netflix
so a ton of people were watching rodrigo
including the most influential mammal
researcher in mexico
who was apparently pretty impressed
he dialed the tv station and asked for
rodrigo's phone number he called me home
and he said listen
if you want to continue learning about
mammals why don't you come over to the
university of mexico the institute of
biology and we will take you to the
field and we will show you mammals for
real so that you can continue
learning about them that's when rodrigo
started using his superpowers for good
once he got hooked on bats he realized
they're victims of a big
misunderstanding
bats have a lot of things going for them
like the fact that they fly and use
echolocation
or the fact that there's so many
different species
and then there are more practical
benefits
take just one bat species as an example
the mexican free-tailed bat
there are tens of millions of them in
mexico alone and even more in the u.s
and they love to eat insects
each million of those bats destroys 10
tons of insects every night so just
imagine what would happen if we lose
those bats overnight well in a few
months we're not going to have any crops
because the insects are going to be
accumulating and accumulating and
accumulating they're going to eat up all
of our crops rodrigo says corn cotton
coffee they all rely on bats to keep
insect numbers down
plus bats also spread seeds and
pollinate some flowering plants
so a healthy bat population means fewer
insects and more fruit and flowers
sounds pretty good right
well this is where the misunderstanding
comes in
rodrigo says you can trace our fear of
bats back to one moment a little more
than 500 years ago it was when the
spanish conquistador air non-cortez
landed on the shores of what's now
mexico
and one of his scribes gonzalo fernandez
de obiedo
notices that the first night that they
spent on the coast of mexico
he saw
these
flying little animals that come out at
night
that land on the horses or under on the
soldiers and bite them to feed on their
blood
these were vampire bats
they're native only to the americas so
the spaniards had never seen them
and they do feed on blood
not human blood except in extremely rare
cases mostly cows
but rodrigo says
that was enough for our minds to start
running
and you know that blood
is a material that
spikes our imagination
you know an animal that is feeding on on
on that sacred liquid
is automatically enshrouded in
in in a
in a sea of mystery
and
our imagination just takes off
and and then we start linking them with
with processes that are really not true
at all
even though just three species of bats
drink blood and there are well over a
thousand species that don't
cortez's account made a connection in
western culture between bats and blood
sucking
so that was the first thing
the second happened a few hundred years
later on the other side of the atlantic
ocean
an irish lad named bram stoker was
cooking up the vampire story that we
know as dracula
turns out that dracula bram stalker's
vampire had this problem that he needed
to to travel very long distances in a
very uh very fast right
so braun stalker stumbles upon this
vampire bat of the new world
and he immediately thinks oh i know what
my vampire will do
he will turn into a bat
fly all of this distance then become
another
human being again and then bite the girl
for her blood and then people run around
saying i want to suck your blood and you
know
and then it's stuck and then the
public image of bats came tumbling down
like crazy and it created a nightmare
for all of us bad biologists in the
world we have been united
to
combat to counter that negative image
that negative image has real world
consequences
it encourages people to hurt bats
and on a bigger level it puts whole
species of bats in danger
the good news is that rodrigo and other
bat scientists have ways of fighting
back
and what could i tell you as a mexican
about tequila you know
coming up how tequila helped rescue an
endangered bat species
salute
that's after the break
for about 12 million years mother nature
fine-tuned a process to grow agave the
plant that's fermented to make tequila
agaves are a type of succulent they have
spiky leaves fanning out kind of in a
spiral
each agave plant waits its entire life
for one single reproductive event when a
tall flower sprouts up out of the middle
of the plant
now that flower is dinner for bats
especially one species called the lesser
long-nosed bat which love to eat agave
nectar they attract
the the bats to come and and lick that
nectar and in the process be completely
covered with their pollen that they are
going to carry to the next the next
agave to the next agave and the next
agave but that process that took
millions of years to perfect
humans threw it out of whack
as people began commercially farming
agave for tequila production they
started to cut corners
they didn't want to wait years for agave
plants to flower naturally so they
cloned agave plants this was cheaper and
easier but it came with a cost
one night in the 1990s rodrigo medellin
was hanging out with some other
scientists
and we were sipping tequila what else
right
and
and then we started talking about how
there was a complete disconnect between
the tequila that we were shipping
and the baths that are responsible for
that tequila
in the 90s the lesser long-nosed bat was
on the endangered species list
and all of the agave cloning was
considered a factor because it takes
away the bat's food
plus rodrigo thought the cloning was
also bad for the tequila industry
natural reproduction creates genetic
diversity but with clones every single
plant shares the same dna one disease
that hits one plant and all of your
plants are going to be sick because
they're all the same they're exactly the
same
so all it takes is for one disease to
hit one plant and you'll be doomed
so rodrigo approached mexico's tequila
regulatory council he proposed a plan
that he thought was a pretty good one
he wanted to allow more natural agave
reproduction he argued it would be good
for the bats and good for tequila so
everybody wins
and i show them pictures etc
and they said
wow that's a fantastic story thank you
very much for telling us and i suggested
a number of
messages there and they said well thank
you very much for coming dr managing
that was fascinating good bye
that was the end of it
yeah he says they didn't really want to
hear it
but rodrigo and some other scientists
were getting pretty concerned that a
catastrophic blight could wipe out
agaves
so rodrigo went back to the tequila
council and they again said wow
thank you very much for coming
fascinating stuff bye
i hope they at least gave you like a
bottle of tequila for the road for your
trouble
not even not even
and then
it happened
rodrigo says around 2010 and 2011 a
disease slammed agave crops a double
whammy of fungus and bacteria
and just like he had warned
it was the big one
and i swear jacob it was not me i didn't
put it in there
it wasn't me right
but then
they reach out and they say oh my god
what was that idea about the bats and
the flowers and the pollen that you were
saying
i said well you're late but let's see
what we can do
now that he finally had the ear of some
tequila producers rodrigo explained his
plan
farmers would manage 95 of their crops
exactly the same as before
but the last five percent would be set
aside for bats to pollinate naturally
which gives the agaves more genetic
diversity and it gives the bats more
food and i explained to them what they
needed to do to allow five percent of
the agaves to flower
and harvest the remaining 95 percent and
that will be their safety passage for
the next generations of agaves and they
immediately said
wow that makes all the sense in the
world why didn't do we do this before so
correct me if i'm wrong but it sounds
like your
sales pitch to the tequila producers is
almost like setting up a savings account
like you put this five percent aside
this is agave that you can't
i guess make profit from now
but
it
keeps your long-term success
looking better exactly it's it's an
insurance policy
in 2016 rodrigo created a pilot program
that certified brands that follow these
rules today those labels have little
logos showing that they're officially
bat friendly tequila
around the same time rodrigo was
starting the program the bat world got
great news
partly because of rodrigo's work
in 2015 mexico removed the lesser
long-nosed bat from its endangered
species list
it was the first mexican mammal ever to
make that kind of improvement
so there were signs that bat
conservation was working
but last year rodrigo ran into his
biggest challenge yet
the coronavirus
now i want to be really clear here when
it comes to the origins of sars cov2
which is the virus that causes covet 19
there's still a lot we just don't know
you may remember that from the beginning
of the pandemic bats have been blamed as
a possible carrier of the virus
and scientists are still investigating
whether bats were the source of the
virus
rodrigo says it is true that bats
naturally carry some coronaviruses
but there's many other groups of mammals
and even birds that have other
coronaviruses
so you cannot say
that bats gave us kovid
so far nobody has pinpointed the exact
source of this coronavirus
and regardless you won't get kovid just
from coming into contact with a bat
with some misinformation claimed bats
could give people covet
even though it was wrong that blame game
has had real and devastating effects on
bats all over the world
in indonesia the government killed
hundreds of bats supposedly for public
safety
in rwanda government officials sprayed
bat colonies with a fire hose
and rodrigo
he followed it all i don't think i have
ever worked harder
than in the past year and a half
trying precisely to
defuse
the
unfounded accusations against baths and
of course when you see that people are
killing bats because of some scientists
saying that bats gave us this
it's not fair jacob
so as far as what you and i can do
rodrigo says
it's pretty simple
be a bat defender
you can go the extra mile by putting up
a bat house in your yard
or for starters just spread the word
talk to your neighbor talk to your
friends talk to your family talk to the
office people
about baths and about what you've
learned in this podcast
rodrigo says you can help out in your
own area too
find out who's conserving bats in your
neighborhood
and maybe even visit a bat cave
you might just surprise yourself and
like it more than you think
it's such a natural
development it's such a natural process
to become
at home at peace in a cave because
remember jacob
that we as human beings
only 10 thousand years ago
only twenty fifty thousand a hundred
thousand years ago we were living in
caves
so caves are our natural home and what
i'm doing is just going back home that's
what i'm doing
if you're ready to learn more about bats
and be a bat defender well we got you
covered
check out more of rodrigo's work
including a short documentary that
follows rodrigo as he looks for a rare
species of vampire bat inside an ancient
mayan ruin
there's a link in our show notes
and you can also find more facts and
figures about bats i mean there's so
much variety on one end of the spectrum
there's the kitty's hognose bat weighs
less than a penny and on the other
flying foxes have a six-foot wingspan
also we have a fun video breaking down
how dracula created some of those
damaging myths about bats
and you can read more about why it's so
tricky to nail down the origins of cobit
19.
plus for subscribers journey into one of
the largest and wildest caves in the
world in borneo
it has caverns so enormous that a
jetliner could fit comfortably inside
and it's home to millions of bats
that's in the show notes right there in
your podcast app
now if you like what you hear and you
want to support more content like this
please rate us and review us in your
podcast app and consider a national
geographic subscription that's the best
way to support overheard go to
natgeo.com
explore to subscribe
[Music]
overheard at national geographic is
produced by alanna strauss brian
gutierrez marcy thompson bianca martin
and me jacob penner
laura sam also helped produce this one
laura best of luck in your next
adventure
our senior editor is eli chen our senior
producer is carla wills
our executive producer of audio is devar
ardulon
our fact-checkers are robin palmer and
julie beer
our copy editor is amy kolzack
hansdale sue composed our theme music
and he sound designed and engineered
this episode
the national geographic society is
committed to illuminating and protecting
the wonder of our world and funds the
work of national geographic explorer at
large rodrigo medellin
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners whitney johnson is
the director of visuals and immersive
experiences susan goldberg is national
geographic's editorial director and i'm
jacob penner thanks for listening we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you